hello welcome to Week in Review with me
Jane seka Kevin McGuire and Eve Pollard
are here to look back at the big stories
of the last seven days that would have
been your big stories to achieve well
the thing that most surprised me was in
her first PMQs Theresa May leant forward
and talking about p bosses not going and
she leant forward in a really Margaret
Thatcher way low over the despatch-box
and said who could that mean mr. Colvin
I mean she looked at him in that
straight way was him I was surprised
Kevin top story yeah I think it's gotta
be the start of the Labour leadership
election Jeremy Corbyn V own Smith I
think will be very very dirty well a lot
more on both of those stories in a
second but first let's get a taste of
what the week was all about
unsurprisingly brexit was on the agenda
for Theresa May's first full week in
office meeting German Chancellor Angela
Merkel and French president Francois
Hollande after facing Mrs May of Prime
Minister's Questions for the first time
Jeremy Corbyn ride fending off the
challenge from his own side he launched
his campaign to remain Labour's leader
Owen Smith now the only rival for the
job a report accused Russia of carrying
out estates on to doping program for its
athletes at the sochi winter olympics
its track and field team were also told
their appeal against a ban from the rio
games had failed Donald Trump accepted
the Republican nomination for president
although the party's convention wasn't
without controversy Turkey's government
reacted to last week's failed coup with
mass arrests of military figures and
sackings and suspensions of leading
judges and academics South African
prosecutors say they'll appeal against
the six-year sentence given to Oscar
Pistorius for murdering his girlfriend
reeva Steenkamp Brandon is shockingly
too lean
on the week when the Sun came out for
summer public health England said we
should all take vitamin D supplements
because we aren't getting enough
sunlight and the Pokemon go crazy and in
one American in trouble the man was
driving while playing the game and
rather than catching a pic achoo he ran
into the back of a police car in
Baltimore fortunately nobody was hurt
well was quite a busy week but but the
olympics were in there I mean do you
think if you think all Russian athletes
should be banned that's what's now being
discussed well I think it would be very
hard to trust them i mean after saatchi
where it was obviously inspired
politically inspired tampering and
people taking drugs and then amazingly a
politically said obviously from Putin
himself they got these tampa free
bottles changed the urine so you
wouldn't test positive for taking drugs
and of course in Sochi more Russians won
medals than anyone else how could you
trust any of them when you know the
government is being right behind taking
drugs you haven't eating any countries
is truly clean dude there's got to be
cheats out there and we are nations
hasn't there no I'm sure I'm sure they
are absolutely happening but it's when
you have a country state-sponsored and
it's organized to that degree and it was
so efficient and so effective and so
terrifying and I'm usually against
collective punishment where you know
some innocent people will be some
innocent athletes will be will be heard
but this was of a completely different
nature to what we've seen before okay
let's move on to politics and this week
to resume took her first steps into
Europe as Prime Minister discussing
among other things the UK leaving the
European Union her meetings with the
German Chancellor Angela Merkel and the
French president Francois Hollande
followed her first Prime Minister's
Questions going head-to-head with jeremy
corbyn here's how it went he refers to
me as the second woman Prime Minister
I've in my years here in this house I've
long heard the Labour Party asking what
the Conservative Party does for women
well
just keeps making us Prime Minister I
suspect that there are many members on
the opposition benches who might be
familiar with an unscrupulous boss a
boss who doesn't listen to his workers a
boss who requires some of his workers to
double their workload
a boss and maybe even a boss who
exploits the rules to further his own
career remind him of anybody well have
you already mentioned it did he did she
remind you of anybody there Kevin oh she
did well and he doesn't think very well
on his feet on these occasions and for
instance he was asking questions of mad
Boris Johnson bringing up his past
attacks on Barrack Obama she doesn't
answer it he doesn't come back to it and
push it home so she's got the theatrics
of it he hasn't totally Blair used to
have the theatrics Gordon Brown wouldn't
when he was Prime Minister and it
matters for your morale of your
eurostile in Parliament but also a lot
of people do watch prime minister's
questions and you can if you look at
good leader there that's bought in the
bag did you shall declare what sastras
is the right way from this mace well
it's probably the right way for her back
benchers I'm not sure it's the right way
for everybody but I would think it's the
right way for her back benches and it
was a bit of fun I mean everybody been
saying how she was very dull and very
boring but actually she was quite witty
and she was quite interesting for the
first PMQs and also I think the fact
that she's prepared to have a go and she
had to go from the very off by
immediately saying she wanted to thank
140 Labour MPs who joined her voting for
trident um it's she just gone on the
attack why not I guess he thinks get on
with it and him briefly we've seen her
traveling across to Germany and to
France this week at pushing British
position but she is going to have to
negotiate Briggs it isn't it's not going
to be easy for her in these European
negotiations over the next few months no
no she began on better with Angela
Merkel and Francois Hollande ins some
ways at out over all honesty she changed
from small shoes too tall shoes yeah to
be honest like a garden gnome wood is
very is rather small not that has
anything wrong or anyone's watching
their small you can still be big in
personality but a schoolgirl French is
as bad as my schoolboy French but she
did come back with Francois Hollande
saying if you want to be in the single
market a lot of jobs lot of trade we
rely on that you're gonna have to accept
free movement so we saw really the
barriers she does face
for election in May and I would be
surprised if he's actually the candidate
because they've had their buoy I don't
you guys know that you're gonna get a
French leader to give on that though I'm
not mom but she's got on better with
Merkel metals was more relaxed about
timing wasn't she well another leader
who's up for election is jeremy corbyn
he was on surer footing on thursday the
launch of his bid to remain party leader
he told her political editor feisal
islam that he was the man to unite the
party we've got a huge support amongst
party members party activists trade
union affiliates members of the
community as a whole obviously I wish
MPs would be more supportive but I hope
that the end of this leadership campaign
they'll recognize as I said in the
opening speech this morning we all have
a duty and an obligation to represent
the people that send us to Parliament
and I hope we can work together so Kevin
is he the man to unite the Labour Party
well we'll find out it's going to be
very difficult for him with with his MPs
but he may have retained the support
amongst Labor members in the in the
country and I think he's quite right
when he says MP should have been more
supportive that I think that coup failed
some didn't give me a chance from the
beginning but it just comes back to the
question if his confidence and he's
credibility wider can you imagine Prime
Minister Jeremy Corbyn in Downing Street
now he thinks he can his supporters
think he can but there is a cult around
him now and I've just met too many
people who used to be labour voters
you've taken against him and what about
Owen Smith even you know is he the man
to take him on did you think and regal
should have dropped out you think labour
should have at least had a woman in
there in the running I don't know that
either of them other ones who really
should take him on ice I suspect there
will be a split I keep hearing that the
parliamentary Labour Party have raised a
lot of money for a split because
actually I think Jeremy Corbyn who
pretends to be everybody's grandpa is
quite threatening with the selection if
you don't follow me you know there will
be G selection and this guy needs this
week that he's not a bully at all he is
not a bully but he lets people bully I
mean I think momentum it's likely is
prolly I mean there never was a culture
of bullying and the Labour Party right
well let's move across Paul
it's the other side of the pond instead
to say that a year ago it may have
seemed impossible perhaps a joke to some
but Donald Trump has now formally
accepted the Republican presidential
nomination and used his convention
speech to set out his stall for his
party and the country this is the legacy
of Hillary Clinton death destruction
terrorism and weakness we will make
America strong again we will make
America proud again we will make America
safe again and we will make America
great again god bless you and good night
can he do it Eve do you think he will
become president can he be Clinton I did
in the end I don't think so but what
nobody really thought of in bricks it is
there are a lot of angry people who feel
that politicians have never been talking
to them don't care about their lives and
of course in America there's the haves
and the have-nots enormous gaps and of
course Mexicans won't vote for him and
other groups won't vote for him but it's
it's quite scary but he's got is this
far and you could actually go all the
way no one thought he would get this far
today not many people thought he would
get no parking no but he was a standout
character in in a Republican field that
was too large and really he says
inflammatory things all the time whether
it's women Muslims Hispanics whoever and
it's kind of nonsense but a lot of
people in in America you're right have a
right to be angry because they've been
dealt a very bad hand but he's not the
answer he's not going to help them with
our homes and get them higher wages and
more secure jobs and better education
for their kids that's right well the
only the only good thing if he ever got
the White House it would be a nightmare
is we would see what he was really like
and he would be exposed as a fraud well
well then the checks and balances also i
miss universe yeah you hope so there are
[ __ ] the court and Congress melosa so
questions to about another Republican al
gaffe of the week and only one contender
this week if you're going to copy
someone's work mrs. Trump perhaps try to
make it somebody a little less
high-profile my parents impressed on me
the values that you work hard for what
you want in life rock and I were raised
with so many of the same values like you
work hard for what you want in life that
your word is your bond and you do what
you say and keep your promise that your
treat people with respect that your word
is your bond that you do what you say
you're gonna do that you treat people
with dignity and respect you think it
overshadowed Trump's nomination this
week or do you think I think we'll
forget it I don't think we will forget
it I mean we disagree about this I tell
you why I I think I feel sorry for
Milania who was obviously given this
piece of paper probably on the morning
she better right no she played a role in
writing it did she I got somebody to
agree to carry the can but they she
wrote no I was just looking at the very
exquisite makeup and my feeling is that
if you can't organize for your wife
speech to be an original speech how are
you gonna deal with Vladimir Putin I
mean it really is important that you
know and I just thought just a tragedy I
mean it will be forgotten up to a point
because we're now go on to the other
convention the Democrats but it's sort
of sticks in your mind slightly did it
did lead to a whole and load of twitter
and hashtag famous Melania Trump quotes
which included things like I have a
dream I did not have sexual relations
with my favorite I would have got away
with it at word p meddling kids but she
also channeled rick astley did you
notice that we said the Trump was would
never give up and never let you down
yeah because you recast in the coming
back okdokey got any royalties for an
Andrea led some of us politics do you
send us in your nominations you can use
the hashtag w in our if you've got a gap
of the week we think we should include
next week time for the right now and our
quick quiz I want to find if you know
what could be a surprise inclusion in
the olympic games in 2024 they don't
know do you know how find out after the
break
that we can review with me Jane second
i'm joined by kevin maguire associate
editor of The Daily Mirror and the
journalist and author Eve Pollard now
before the break we asked which sport
could be the surprise inclusion in the
Olympic Games and twenty twenty four
black faces around the table risky's
tiddlywinks Oh what's up I it is the
medieval sport of jousting knowledge
heritage are leading the calls for
jewels to be part of the game this isn't
an april fool and they argue that it's
surfing climbing call the skateboarding
can all be included why not jesting can
you imagine taking drugs and then
getting on the horse i know i suspect i
suspect most of the world never got into
jousting this is behaving properly on
today I think what you think about
things like dressage not that I'm
diminishing dressage but it is
essentially getting the horse to do
something yeah slightly very intricate
yes it's a similar sort of thing isn't
it but I think it would be quite
ridiculous don't you I mean let's not go
further back dress I know you don't want
to diminish what a lousy sport well it's
the Horsham should get the Medal yeah
yeah by the English Heritage we disagree
but we'll find out it's it it's up there
in the list anyway right now this week
the fallout from the failed coup in
Turkey continued on Middle East
correspondent Alex Rossi was there and
Senate's report this closed circuit
television shows a lone figure running
into the road to try and stop a speeding
tank in its tracks incredibly he
survives this
and a second attempt to stop another
tank the pictures have become a symbol
of the people power thats watered the
uprising other images are also emerging
from Friday night showing soldiers
aiming their guns and firing at
civilians the Turkish government has
admitted the attempted coup nearly
succeeded and across the country the
crackdown continues 99 Admirals and
generals who've been paraded before the
cameras on their way into courts have
now been charged it is a substantial
part of the military which was once
revered in this country tens of
thousands of people have also been
forced to resign from their jobs in the
police judiciary and education academics
have been banned from traveling abroad
as the purge on state institutions grows
in scale in fact anyone suspected of
having links to this man Petula Gulen
who's accused of masterminding the coup
is a target from his base in the United
States Gulen has denied involvement but
turkey says it's provided us officials
with evidence and is demanding his
extradition president Irwin's critics
accuse him of using the purge to silence
his enemies he's promising to introduce
new legislation and cleanse the
country's institutions of the virus
responsible for the plots Kevin what
future do you hit now for Turkey I think
it's very grim state of emergency Human
Rights suspended must be 60,000 people
now have lost their jobs or being
arrested and the reaction will be
terrible from early one who's very
authoritarian was pushing turkey down of
a very religious roared which very very
care product Aviv here if you a
secularist so now I think it is really
really grim photo I think it the coup
was wrong people who oppose earlier one
opposed to coutu but they will be made
to suffer a lot of talk about potential
of Turkey joining the EU
d that was sort of nonsense I mean it
was they were nowhere near joining me
you for all sorts of reasons but here
you have this this cleric who lives in
America who's a liberal Islamist and
then you've got a deghan who of course
in the meantime while he's arresting all
these people is having a go at the curve
is having a go at everybody who was
against him and it will become a
dictatorship I'm afraid he's the new
Sultan he will take control he will not
Brook any opposition right let's have a
look at your paper stories of the week
at Eve to you first it appears that you
can be too healthy to have a doctor now
it seems crazy to me and apparently if
you haven't visited your doctor for five
years you get crossed off the list they
send you two letters and then you get
crossed off the list I thought the whole
point was you should start try and stay
healthy and not cost you per NHS I mean
I dis apparently something to do with
GPS pay and they're apparently lots of
ghosts list yeah deserters get 136
pounds for each patient that they have
and if that patient no longer exists or
has moved the argument is and I can
imagine that that's the system that
doesn't probably work very well people
move away people die they don't get off
the list they've got to be a more
sensible way to pay GPS and / ahead
because also you know in a different
area you might have people who are much
healthier the southeast supposed to be
healthier than the north the weather's
better and if you might live in an area
where there lots of babies being born
you've got a lot more work seems a crazy
way to pay them and I'm really worried
that older people will get these two
letters may not tweet fall apart yeah
they worrying if a GP doesn't notice
you've died so you know you don't need
to be on a list of thought they see the
body that's no real Eva at the sale of
arm holdings air I'm Holdings this week
was painted as a great deal for British
business but possibly not such a great
deal for everybody I think it's very
very sad that we have these great
businesses by the way I'm not up to all
technical things but I didn't realize
this was this genius business started in
Britain and act
it's in all of our phones it's in every
technical thing we lot of us had no idea
of knowing around a bit of this guy
absolutely and also very bad i think for
financial pages that didn't warn us and
didn't tell us about it the fact is
going to now be owned by the japanese
probably means it's terribly safe but
it's a pity that such a great british
business and it's off do you think we
should be fighting to keep these kind of
business or do you think it's just you
know its market it's the world and
companies should be free to be bought by
whoever wants yeah but you can you can
stop that happening if you like if you
will have the law to try and protect it
because if you have them headquartered
here you have more control LS ideas sack
people and remember Cadbury's have an
end they bought by the Americans closed
a factory near Bristol and change and
one thing some of the some of the
foreign owners are good tartar have been
very good jaguar land rover steel less
haw but now I I'd rather have companies
owned and based here at Kevin your final
paper choice this week happy new for
Pippa Middleton yep she's getting
married to this James both use 200,000
pounds engagement ring come I would
ridiculous what's she gonna do about the
bridesmaids you're gonna make sure she's
got a big bottom or something they're
gonna be overshadowed out what happened
that her sister's wedding adaptions of
Cambridge I see I think it was a very
nice thing the Duchess of Cambridge on
her wedding day let her bridesmaid also
wear white wasn't saying I'm gonna put
her in horrible pink or peach year she
got you're going to be and more you know
and I think what would be very nice is
if she reaches the matron of honor yeah
and possibly where's Charlotte
absolutely we're getting excited about
already Kevin's just shaking okay bear
you're a friend for your mum I've
comparing a dress the shoes yeah the Hat
just Falls to wish the couple well as I
would any other but I just have to
cannot stand it and you're quite right
oh thank you thank you Joe vegetative
papers what about your ups and downs now
does this even get you going Kevin what
about romance in this story this is yves
first choice you're sending up you're
setting up a couple who met well he was
the tweeter at waterstone and she fell
in love with his picture where the
surface and
she read his treats which I think are
quite funny and quite literally I think
in this day and age of illiteracy we
should be pleased and they eventually
met Mary this was our first tweet well
i'm in love with whoever's manning the
water Stones Orchestra account be still
my actual beating heart and this is the
ones you sent in a wedding day yes oh
dear reader I bear Oh family [ __ ] Jane
Jane either yeah but I love that I've
got a romantic card it's a picker and
James well I wish I will shut this cut
but I feel a bit more sincere about
whooshing okay well wait yeah we send
them well it's a lovely story so
everybody loves it so we're sending them
up as a movie doesn't even say the names
that we should we should have said it
right there Jonathan of a Victorian
Jonathan that's them yes and you're
sending them believe the people who got
stuck in ikea is car park for three
hours and reading well let me just tell
anybody if you want to get divorced the
best thing is it so i care i think i've
never been to ikea with my husband
without having an Argus we have a route
in the store what first one we have our
back going then when you get there you
have a robot in the straw and they range
it so you have to walk miles you guys
for everything and you go through
everything and then of course around
what you're gonna buy about then you
Ryback finding it and if you want to
divorce my suggestion go to ikea on the
saturday always way if you can't get the
boxes in you know you're trying to put
them up so a second thing ikea at its
car parked down at Kevin you're sending
up Sam Allardyce whistle waiting fed to
be confirmed we are there as England
manager is that we've manager son and my
team wish she was staying when he was at
Newcastle we call it fat Sam so let me
call him big son when he goes 20
desserts doesn't goes to England he's
fat some again all right I thinks a
valid eyes up good me for him maybe not
to get for sunderland but you're sending
down at Robert Doyle now who's a burglar
who was nabbed by what he nibbled Corey
definitely every time he broke into
somewhere he'd eat something like a
piece of cake or he left half a whisper
so the cops got him varies DNA so he's
dozy and daft as well as nasty got 20
weeks and the local paper made the most
of it with a headline careless with
very that were ever so we're sending it
down thank you both very much well thank
you don't forget to send us also your
nominations if you don't nominations for
ups and down using the hashtag W in our
well thank you very much for joining us
for our review of the week we'll be back
with much more next week but for now
it's goodbye from them goodbye goodbye
at it's goodbye from me goodbye